buenas tardes sentido duda la imagen más
triste del funeral la reina isabel
la monarca completamente sola sin poder
tener el apoyo físico o moral de alguno
de sus hijos despidiendo a su esposo por
73 años y que fue fundamental para su
vida como ella misma lo ha dicho una
imagen con la que seguramente millones
de personas en todo el mundo se
identificarán por esta pandemia del cobi
19 se sabe que la reina isabel goza de
muy buena salud de hecho el próximo
miércoles 21 de abril cumplirá 95 años y
un día después el 22 de abril regresará
a sus labores incluso antes de que la
reina ascendiera el trono en 1952 juro
que todos los días de su vida y hasta la
muerte estaría dedicada a la corona así
que no se espera que abdique en su hijo
carlos pero lo que sí está sucediendo
hace algunos años es que la monarca está
accediendo y otorgando cada vez más
responsabilidades y más funciones en el
heredero
el príncipe carlos y eso será lo que
seguramente seguirá sucediendo luisa y
esta fecha además reunió a la familia de
forma obligada a verdad una familia que
recordemos ha atravesado especialmente
en los últimos tiempos varios conflictos
que tomaron resonancia pública
otra de las imágenes del día la del
príncipe harry y su hermano william
caminando juntos con kate middleton
después de finalizado el funeral una de
las imágenes más esperadas aquí a nivel
interno luego de que el príncipe harry
con su esposa mega marco el yerno una
entrevista en la que hablarán y
denunciarán racismo en la familia real
así que era una de las imágenes más
esperadas la que se espera sea la
reconciliación de harry con su hermano y
con su familia